okay chairs you're now live on youtube
thank you over to you jill
thank you phil good afternoon
everyone and welcome to this uh joint
meeting
it's a pleasure to have a joint meeting
with our friends in torridge
uh as we're certainly living through
very
strange times at the moment and uh we
all hope that
uh by next year we should be back to
normal sitting around the table
and i will able to see and talk to each
other
face to face so um welcome to the
meeting
right orianna i'd just like you to read
out please the
etiquette and that for this afternoon's
meeting
yes course chair thank you
okay um so welcome to this climate
disorder subcommittee as chair said this
is a joint meeting between north devon
council and torres district council's um
external overview and scrutiny
uh just a reminder that the meeting is
being held in accordance with the local
authority meetings regulations
which means that remote attendance is
permitted as long as certain conditions
are satisfied
these include that participants are able
to hear and be heard by others in
attendance
i hope everyone can hear me okay
just to confirm chair that uh members of
north devon committee that are present
i have yourself counsellor bullard
councillor joy cann
councillor gubb councillor
mack councillor derek speer councillor
lisbear
council york and we also have council
leaver and councillor warden present
um so we're using zoom today is the
formal meeting of the council please
make sure that you are aware of what's
in screenshot behind you
your video camera should only be on when
you're invited to speak
and please get your microphones muted to
help with the quality of the call
turn off any other unnecessary
microphones in in the room that you're
sitting in and just
raise your hand using the blue raised
hand function
on the menu bar if you wish to speak and
speak when you're invited to
likewise when we do a vote i believe
um it will be moved and seconded and
then i'll have to run through chair if
you're happy
everyone's vote okay um
and yes we are being videoed live
stream to youtube i believe so thank you
thank you very much orianna have we got
any apologies for absence please
uh yesterday i've received apologies of
absence from councillors henderson
and orange right moving on to item three
of the north devon council agenda
to prove a correct record of the minutes
of the meeting held on the 31st of
october
2019 pages five to eight i would like to
move
that those are approved and accepted
have i got a seconder please
i can't see any hands as yet chair um
could i have a second to please for the
minutes of the
of the third yes there we go councillor
york and council lisbear so we have we
have a second day yeah
right thank you very much do you wish to
take a vote on that now
uh yes i mean there were only a few of
you there so i'll go to yourself first
chair how would you like to vote
approve thank you very much and i
believe councillor york you were present
at that meeting
yes approved thank you so much
councillor liz spear
approve thank you uh councillor robbie
mack i believe you were there
how would you like to vote i approve
please
thank you so much uh apologies if i've
missed anyone but i think that was all
that was present
yes that's carried right thank you very
much we now go on to
our item four items brought forward
which in the opinion of the chair
should be uh considered uh by the chair
um i have had a request from councillor
robbie mack
who would like to say just a few short
words
uh regarding right white ribbon day so
robbie over to you please
thank you chairman i'll be very brief um
i
just noticed this is white ribbon day um
again this year
last year there were a small gathering
and bastable square to market
and obviously it's very sad that we
can't market
publicly um and i'm aware that this will
obviously be forming a large part of the
police's job over over the last year um
and it's also in the in the agenda in
the report today
um and yeah just a thought for anybody
who's suffering domestic
violence because obviously these
problems are exacerbated by lockdown and
restricted movement
and um just just something for the two
committees to be aware of thank you
chairman
thank you very much sir robbie thank you
uh item five on our agenda is any
declarations of
interest uh orianna please
i've received none chair thank you
and uh item six to agree the agenda
between part a
and part b well we haven't got any part
b
so we will now go to item seven
which is the uh presentation
chair yes uh can i just do the torridge
preliminaries as well
uh yes if you like yeah just to get us
to the same point
so that we can thank you very much um
i'm speaking now on behalf of porridge i
am phil pennington chair of uh
external uh uh ovule scrutiny for thor
district council
and again welcome the opportunity to
work both with all the areas of our
community uh service uh with the police
etc
um and north devon district council um
i'm going through our agenda for our
tour district councillors
um mary is either apologies for absence
or can you just do a roll call of who's
present please
agenda item yeah we have no apologies
and everybody's present
thank you very much indeed um agenda
item number two
um we did our minutes uh for last year's
meeting the 31st of october meeting 2019
um other previous meetings last year
and i would like to have the agreement
of our committee that we can move our
minutes
um to later in the meeting when we will
go individually
to look at our own plan i would just
like to make sure that our committee is
in agreement with that that i can
move move agenda item to
minutes of the mini meeting of the 14th
of october
to after the presentation and discussion
of the
community safety partnership so anybody
objecting just show or shout now
and i assume i am going to take a vote
or maybe i have to but
for ease just sure if you disagree with
that i don't see any blue hands from
torrance committee members
so therefore we will move the minutes to
after the presentation and discussion on
the community's
partnership again um like uh
north devon district uh we have no
public participation
offers here item number three the action
list i propose to take later as soon as
we've agreed to move
it item number five declaration of
interest you all know the routine
and item number six agreement between
agenda items one and two
no part two for us either and number
seven
i have proposed that we would bring any
urgent matters for torridge after
the presentation of the csp any of our
committee disagree with that change of
agenda
no good back to you chairman tucker
please to lead us now
into the presentation thank you uh
councillor pennington um on to item
seven it's my pleasure
on behalf of north devon and torridge to
welcome toby davis to our meeting today
and uh toby i know you very kindly
provided us with uh nine pages of update
but uh over to you to go through that
update please
and then we would like if there is a few
questions from
members of north devon and then we'll go
over to cancer pennington to see if
there's any questions
that we have from torrid so over to you
toby
okay first thing could just confirm can
you see me i'm not oh fail zoom it's on
my own personal phone you can see me
we can see and hear you loud and clear
that that's first
first hurdle overcome so so welcome
everybody uh toby davies i'm the local
policing area commander for
north and uh west devon uh you've all
had the report that's been produced by
the team uh i hope you had a chance to
read through that but i'm just gonna go
through a few things
and i'm going to bring the team in as
well they're going to give you little
bite size updates around some of the
work
that's been ongoing and hopefully
opportunity then for you to ask
any questions so i just thought i'd
start having a discussion with joe and
phil last week
just a brief explanation around the
community partnership remind us as to
what
how this came about so back in 1998
uh then whoever was in government back
at that time
the crime of disorder act came into
place uh which in essence
uh made it law that we are required
as part of agencies to work together
with the aim
of improving community safety and part
of the thinking
was they were trying to make it clear
that everybody had a responsibility
around community safety
perhaps there was a perception sometimes
it was just the police
so from a district council perspective
obviously you've got a really really
important role
uh and that is around administrating and
making that partnership happen
and you have community safety managers
across both districts
uh in fairness they have a lot of other
stuff on top of that but they also do
do that role and do a very good job so
in north devon toys district
technically is two csps csp in each area
but for expedience
and magnetism clearly we're working up
uh as one communicator partnership which
makes absolute sense
so i'm the current chair of the north
devon torridge
uh csp however of course it could be any
agency
uh and at some time i'm sure somebody
else would like to come in there and
take over
take over the role so we meet we meet
as a wider group we meet uh quarterly
and there's lots of subgroups around
specific areas of business so
anti-social behavior
we've got a road safety group domestic
abuse sexual violence group
we have lots of our members sit on uh on
peninsula wide or county level groups
around
uh whether it's county lines monday
slavery
and the like as well so that's the wider
the wider parts of the meeting
but in reality every day business as
usual
the partners are just by our very nature
we're working together
in any case so the partners that are the
sitting is part of the community
partnership are the local authorities
clearly north devon district and
torridge
devon county council police fire
public health north dakota healthcare
trust you have elected members that
you've nominated
on both sides so phil hackett caroline
lever and we've got county as well
uh that's obviously set in the um
in the partnership we also have
probation domestic abuse
services alcohol services drug services
lots of voluntary services and anybody
else that's relevant to whatever topic
we're we're talking about and we
consider the local priorities
understandably around anti-social
behavior crime vulnerability
but we also have a legal duty to
consider the national priorities around
counter-terrorism prevent
uh monday slavery just today name a few
and there's a few other functions the
government have added over time
for example if we have a domestic murder
or
or suicide then there is a obligation
for us to do a review and to take some
learning
from uh from those as well so if we were
going to go and look at this and do a
review nationally
around how the crime disorder back in
1998
how it's now translated into those
communicated partnerships it'd be very
mixed
there are some areas that literally do
once a year they meet
they tick the box met their legal
obligation go back into their silos
fortunately here we're in a really good
place i think by our very nature
about our geography we work very very
well together
and we've gone a step further so the
community partnership
here isn't just about the meeting for
many years i think most of you know
we've got a partnership team
so the district councils and police have
we put resources together
uh who are working on a on a more
regular day-to-day business
um business as usual so in a really good
place which means a lot of stuff is
happening
between those meetings any case just to
explain at a county level
whilst there's a legal duty for us to
have additional to have a csp
at county level there is also a safer
devon partnership
so the chairs of all the community
partnerships around devon
we all attend a county level uh safer
devon partnership which also has county
level strategic leads that
that come to that meeting so it ensures
that a lot of our themes
uh and areas of business are being uh
considered across
the peninsula and funding wise we're all
throwing in our resource our time our
energy myself police
we're all here in terms of our the
resource time that we give to it
but the p the police and crime
commissioner also provides funding it's
it's it's not
massive and uh it previously it's been a
lump sum
uh which comes in uh albeit in the last
couple of days we've just been advised
that
uh for next year it's gonna be different
next year we're gonna have to bid
for each aspect that we um put anything
that we want and obviously provides some
kind of rationale as to
uh where it's gonna go and how it links
to the police crime plan
so before i go on and just to set the
context for this year a bit of cobid
so i just stop and pause for a second uh
joe is there any
any i can't see the screen with that
hands up or the like you have to tell me
no i think toby it's fine if you carry
on and
do your presentation and then we will
have
a question or two after but you carry on
thank you perfect okay thank you so just
to set the scene
and the context uh i don't think it
comes as a surprise to any of you to uh
to recognize that
the covid and the the pandemic is
clearly
uh has consumed most of our time
and activity whether that's the
partnership or whether it was as
individual agencies
just to provide reassurance the uh the
emergency response to that
kicked in uh and at a partnership level
there's a partnership structures were
established across the whole county and
across the region
we then feed into the into the national
picture
and and all of the csp members have been
really really fully engaged
uh in those partnership processes i
won't go through it or
do complicated to explain here uh what i
can say that the response that we've
given in my view
has been fantastic response from from
all the partners
emergency services uh in terms of
responding to that
and i would equally say that it's a
divisive issue at times but it's
been a very balanced response as well
from our area in terms of how we've been
handling that so i make no apologies in
saying
that for each of the agencies on a
partnership clearly dealing with that
immediate and continuing pandemic threat
is still top of the agenda but at the
same time
and per probably today's meeting as well
is to ensure
that we're still looking out for those
areas of vulnerability or community
safety uh concerns and ensure they're
still
being addressed um so that kind of
carries on
i can't help but mention i i accept this
isn't about the partnership as a whole
but equally at the same time i think
most of you probably aware as well we
had a a critical incident back in march
uh with relation to the basketball
police station uh
so we were advised back then that the
roof uh was
was not sound uh and we had to vacate
the building so
that's meant that over the same time
period we've been moving hundreds of
staff
now to three new sites uh across
barnesville and i'm sure most of you
probably aware at the main site
the 17 brethren site has now been
established so we've just got our
custody
to move across so it's been a a mightily
challenging year
not just a police perspective but from
everyone's perspective so just to give
you an overview
of where we are and then i'm going to
come to reach a few of the team to give
us some updates on specifics so
um the crime as a whole we're down 13
percent
uh which equates to about 1300
less crimes this year over last year yes
clearly covid has an impact
um but the reality is nationally that
crime reduction is around five percent
so we have we have gone far far far
further
in those reductions than we have
nationally
i think the other thing which is really
pleasing is that
our outcomes so in terms of our ability
to
catch the offender and detect those
crimes is the highest in region
uh and that's not just down to police
that is down to the partnership the
community support you're going to hear
in a minute the brilliant work around
intelligence sharing
proactivity joint operations that's what
brings in the results and the community
support
enables us to catch the offenders
there's been a couple of crime areas
where we've seen an increase
drug trafficking and weapons
and just to provide again reassurance
that's actually it sounds perverse
that's quite a good thing
because the reality is if i was we were
all sat back doing nothing we wouldn't
be
catching the bad guys and we wouldn't be
recording those crimes
so it's only through our really
proactive response you'll hear about
some of that in a minute from the
partnership that we're going in
catching those counted lines groups
catching the offenders
and recording those those crimes so
those increases are a positive
an area less positive but has a a slight
double-edged sword is around hate crime
we have seen an increase in our
hate crime activity over the last 12
months so
it's good that people are feeling
encouraged to report
but clearly of concern we have looked at
patterns and there's nothing
uh discernible in those in those
patterns but something we are going to
clearly carefully uh monitor
the other area before i come to
conclusion is asb
uh so anti-social behavior we have seen
increased levels of and social behavior
now
much of that is kobe related because now
if somebody's in a gathering
uh in breach of social distancing or
second homes they were being recorded as
asb so you can't really can make
comparisons
but i think it'd be fair to say
anecdotally we are getting
a lot more reports around asb and the
town centers advancement
in particular street attached alcohol uh
and some of those behaviors and you're
gonna hear some really good stuff
that's been going on for the asb
steering group around that
but but in summary we remain
and i'm proud to say one of the safest
areas that you can live
in the country the head of population
there is nowhere
uh of an area of our size that has such
uh
low levels of crime and that is down and
it keeps going down that is down to the
to the work of the emergency services
and the partnership uh coming together
so
what i'd like to do is i'll just come to
some of those uh more specifics joe and
i will just then just give a very brief
minute uh i'll cover off some of the
stuff that we're gonna look at
for next year so um
shall i come to dean from torridge are
you happy dean to come to go first
i sh just what is the question toby
sorry you happy to go first at home
no sorry phil the ex just explained the
um i've got
dean uh dean smith tim burt whistle and
noel
who are going to give just very brief
updates around specific pieces of work
they're involved in
fine if it's okay with uh chairman
tucker i'm happy to go first
unless unless you unless a particular
need to i was gonna uh
assume we'd look for questions be after
my colleagues had spoken okay yeah fine
does any other
any of the committee from torres have
any questions
at the present moment i haven't got any
hands going up
okay carry on okay so
i'm handing you over to to dean first
then please thank you very much indeed
dean please lead us thank you toby
can everyone uh stay and hear me okay
yes wendy
thank you good afternoon chairs and good
afternoon everyone
uh for anyone who doesn't know me um i'm
dean smith
and i'm the community safety lead
officer for institution council
and i'm also the social behaviour lead
officer as well
um and obviously what we're going to do
um myself
uh police sergeant mel borg who's our
partnership sergeant
uh tim burt whissel uh from north devon
uh community safety partnership
we're just going to give you some
highlights some of the excellent work
uh that we've done as a community safety
partnership over the last 12 months
uh but as you can imagine as toby has
touched on we've been extremely busy
since our last report to you
obviously 2020 has been dominated by
kobe 19
which obviously has given rise to
additional challenges
beyond those challenges that we face on
a day-to-day basis dealing with
community safety
so i just want to touch on a few of the
activities and projects
uh that we've all worked on during the
past 12 months
and i must stress it is a partnership
led approach and we work not only
together quite
quite close with north devon but also
close with all our partners external
partners
including probation health uh
fire and police obviously as many of you
know
our partnership has pioneered and the
bike size training inputs
which are mini one to two hour input
sessions on emerging issues
uh and around important themes that are
affecting our communities right now
and obviously but as as a result of kobe
19
we did have to suspend those um training
inputs
and those were suspended from march uh
2020
for obvious reasons as we couldn't do
any face-to-face delivery
but up until that point we did cover up
some really important sessions
around county lines exploitation
modern slavery prevent and
radicalization
and suicide prevention and intervention
but more importantly we have run a
recent online session
uh by teams and that was specifically on
cyber safety and scams
so going forward we will now start to
deliver a 2021 program of online
sessions
on our new virtual platform which is
quite exciting
for us all to be able to do that and
deliver that
as a community safety partnership our
funding comes from the office and police
and crime commissioner
and as toby has already touched on we
get this on an annual basis
and as a joint partnership we receive 25
000 pounds which doesn't sound a lot of
money however we're quite proud that we
can
utilize this quite effectively uh
jointly
in turrican north devon our expense
spending intentions have to be ratified
on an annual basis by the opcc
and this is on an annual basis and it
has to formalize
and follow the prison police and crime
plan and they have specific priority
areas
which include areas like connecting
communities and policing
preventing them deterring crime and
protecting people from risk of abuse and
supporting victims
now some of those projects and
deliveries that we've spent our money on
so far this year are programs around our
street marshall scheme
now obviously when the night clubs
closed in march 2020
we were delivering a really unique
scheme in both uh dev
and north devon and turret where it was
a joint partnership with our local
businesses and it was a marshalling
scheme
that helped protect and safeguard our
evening nighttime economy
so those marshals when the pubs and
clubs would close
would put on flesh and jackets and
they'd be there in the community
to support people and ensure that they
were dispersed
in an in an orderly fashion away from
our town
centres obviously nightclubs um closed
in march
so we haven't been able to deliver that
so far this year
other schemes that we delivered on is
close circuit television cameras
uh to disrupt and prevent
county lines it was an idea that was
developed in conjunction with the force
intelligence unit with devon and
cornwall police
and i'd say this would be over cans that
are being utilized
to safeguard our most vulnerable in the
community from those organized crime
groups
who potentially are subject and victim
of our dangerous drugs networks other
issues and other
projects that we're dealing on mediation
services
which is a service we use quite
frequently in our environmental health
setting
to support people in our community who
are potentially having issues
and neighbour disputes uh we're able to
fund a mediation service which we then
offer free to our victims which is
greatly received and supported
and they have some very very good data
in relation to their engagement with our
communities
on an annual basis obviously we have our
usual crime prevention engagement tools
and we work quite closely with the crime
prevention officer
with devon and cornwell police and help
assist in areas of core blockers
preventing scams we also in 2020 at the
beginning of the year
delivered a fantastic trauma reform
conference
which i know uh tim is going to talk to
you a little bit more about
a bit later on obviously one area i
wanted to touch on was road safety
and it's always been recognized as an
emerging threat here in north devon
but we're pleased that as a partnership
we're now represented at the north and
devon road safety forum
and um i and uh myself and tim burton
we attend regular meetings which are
held
to discuss road safety issues within our
district
and again this is fully supported by us
as a community safety partnership
and indeed the opcc and obviously
we also support operation snap which is
the new northern devon scheme
that allows the public to update upload
dash cam footage from their vehicles
to help prevent uh and detect uh road
crime
and road policing issues and is fully
supported by the public
uh going forward we're also proud that
we'll be able to contribute
to the honest truth scheme which
provided approved driving instructors
information packs so they can convey
right
vital road safety messages to all new
our new drivers whatever their age might
be
what i'm going to do now is pass you
over to police sergeant noel borg
who's going to talk to you about some of
the other projects
that we've delivered on this community
safety partnership
now it's over to you
thank you dean good afternoon everyone
as dean mentioned my name's noel burke
i'm the community safety police sergeant
i'm uh based in barnstable in
brinsworthy
however i cover both barnstable and
torridge north devon and torridge
and i've been asked today to to talk
about some of the uh
some of the work we've undertaken over
the last year um
based on the priorities we've set
ourselves so the four areas of work i'll
be talking about is county lines
um which i'll be disappointed if no
one's heard about county lines
modern slavery under an operation of
operation aidan's
the safer towns which was a successful
uh
bid we've put in for funding for safer
towns within ilfracome barnesville
and biddeford and finally a project
uh under the banner of the high
intensity partnership which is police
working
alongside partners from mental health
so starting with county lines obviously
county lines is
is those people gangs who would choose
to uh
to deliver dangerous drugs within north
devon uh generally heroin and crack
uh it's fair to say we've experienced
over the last few years
uh an increase in this type of activity
uh but in order to to uh
to counteract that and to drive that
type of activity away
we've raised the profile because we
really recognize the value
of intelligence uh intelligence is the
lifeblood of our organization we really
rely on the community
and those partners we work with to
provide us with the intelligence
two really good examples is housing
provided us with intelligence that a
young girl
who had recently housed was back on the
streets
we very quickly and this was it probably
about eight months ago we very quickly
turned that around
executed a warrant at the premises and
found two members of a gang from london
who
who cooked the premises i.e they'd gone
into the premises
made various threats and intimidations
for his young girl and we're using the
premises to deal drugs in barnstable
and another example was our outreach
team so the teams who on a daily basis
are going out
to support the homeless community in a
street attack community
we're providing us intelligence about a
young male
who was disappearing out of uh
barnstable town
and appearing back um over a sporadic
period of time and appeared to have a
lot of money
we again executed a warrant at our
premises and found a large amount of
cash
and drugs again that just demonstrates
the real value
in intelligence um and and the the fact
that we rely on on our community
our elected members um to provide that
intelligence to us
uh so in terms of county lines we've
seen we've significantly reduced the
amount of gangs
who uh appear within our community in
north devon
the intelligence from the gangs
themselves because believe it or not we
get intelligence back via
our our other organizations in london
and liverpool and birmingham which are
the main areas we find the gangs coming
from
and the intelligence is that north devon
is really difficult to penetrate
in terms of delivering drugs the result
of that is it's enabled us now
to identify the gangs uh within london
and liverpool who are
predominantly responsible for for
delivering drugs within the area
we're now taking the battle to both
liverpool and london and we've
recently successfully had london and
liverpool arrest persons on our behalf
we bring them back down to our force and
we've charged them
with numerous offenses so we're getting
to the to the source of the drugs
because we've enabled that to happen via
the intelligence you provided to us
and allowing us the time and space by
not having gangs appear in our area to
go back to the areas
and and deal with those at source so
that's a fantastic
demonstration of how as a partnership we
we do some really important work
but actually we rely on the intelligence
provided to us uh if i could make one
um request is we are rolling out as dean
mentioned
bite size training we had our first one
two weeks ago in terms of scams it
wasn't particularly well attended but we
get that it was the first one
people are still finding their feet but
as we move forward we will be launching
bite-sized training
for county lines and various other
initiatives
and we'd really welcome a large
attendance and we're more than happy to
do it on zoom
but it really is about raising the
profile of these emerging issues
and how you can support us in the
delivery of them
moving on to modern slavery we do we
also recognize that
there is modern slavery in in north
devon so we had our agents we worked
with
um our regional organized crime teams
trading standards
environmental services hmrc and dwp
and the primary drive behind that was
agricultural textile premises
car washes and nail bars
where ordinarily you tend to find people
who've been trafficked into the area
and i paid significantly low wages
many against their will and to deliver a
service
so we visited up to 30 premises in north
devon
and and the feedback is we've we've
identified very small amounts
of modern slavery but we're also there
to provide
support uh and guidance to these
premises in terms of what they can and
can't do
and again that was a real a positive um
response to
the work we're doing um two final ones
safer towns i mentioned about funding
we've been successful in uh uh three
successful funding bids
five thousand pound for torridge uh for
barnstable and ilfra comb
intolerance has been used for outreach
so what the
um the outreach teams those people who
work with the street attached
with the homeless those responsible
largely for the asb we've seen
in torridge are being visited on a daily
basis by the outreach teams they've been
offered
all of the support that the outreach
teams provide
including finance housing advice
medical clinical and so on and so forth
and the benefits for that as a police
organization is
we're saying to them grasp this
opportunity because if you don't
then the option for us will be go to
court
we'll present you to court and we'll
also demonstrate that you have been
given the opportunity
with all of this funding to embrace the
outreach work that's provided to you
and we call that the dual pathway so
there's two pathways there's the one
where you embrace
all of the work provided to you the
other one is the criminal justice system
and we've already um dealt with two
people via that where we've evidenced
the core that they've had all of the
opportunity
and have chosen not to grasp that
opportunity
and finally i mentioned the
high-intensity partnership which is the
collaboration
between police and mental health
services that's been ongoing for 12
months now
and it's working with a cohort of about
12 people
across north devon who are a massive
demand on resources
so in biddeford there's one female who
appears on biddeford bridge
and numerous times um she's clearly got
all sorts of underlying health
conditions
uh but the impact on police resort uh
resources
ambulance fire and the impact on the
town is significant
so we've worked very closely with mental
health and again we've applied that dual
pathway
engage with the all the support that's
provided take all your medication
we'll work very closely but from a
police point of view we'll provide the
boundaries
and if you step over the boundaries and
we are very sympathetic and
compassionate
to the issues you you've clearly got but
nevertheless the behavior is you're
displaying
the mental health services are telling
us this is behavioral and it's not
mental health
so we've seen a significant reduction in
that female on the bridge in biddeford
and i've got no doubt whatever torridge
have felt the benefits of that
um so what we've seen certainly from a
police point of view with the 12 people
we've currently worked with we've seen a
reduction
a significant reduction in our demand
whilst uh servicing that demand but also
in the region of about 60 thousand pound
saving by working very closely
with mental health services that's a
very
quick snapshot of some of the work we've
we've done i'll now
hand you over to uh tim burtwhistle who
will provide you with an update in
relation to all of our matters thank you
so much
hello can you hear me to see me before i
start we can hear and see you very well
tim
excellent news okay welcome
uh welcome to uh thank you for inviting
us to the meeting
this afternoon i'm gonna talk about
three uh areas of work that we
undertook this year and they are all
it's kind of new to us really
um they are all um areas that we hadn't
really dealt with before
um i'm going sorry i'm just going to get
to my
correct screen on my other computer
yeah so um the first one being the safer
summer scheme which was i think toby
mentioned earlier and dean
dean briefly mentioned as well the
second one is our involvement in the
adolescent safety framework which is a
new a new initiative by
children's social care and third and
finally i'm going to talk about
um our trauma informed conference um
which is
uh i think the start of something quite
exciting for us there
that should happen in the forthcoming uh
weeks months and years so we'll start
with the safer summer scheme
um in july 2020 and the office of the
police and crime commissioner launched a
fund uh
to prove to promote uh covert safety uh
for the summer
um tourist period
um it was prom
it was predicted and it transpired the
extra visitor numbers would
would um arrive in our area because of
the restrictions um for
foreign travel that covid unfortunately
bran
brought um
the the office of the police and crime
commissioner commissioner identified
um towns across devon and cornwall um
for the for the marshals to um operate
in
and in our area uh in north devon
so it's sorry excuse me
in our area it was croydon welcome in
north devon
and westwood hill in turridge um we
managed to negotiate a presence
in biddeford because we felt that it was
important our local knowledge
suggested that um biddeford would be an
area that would be affected and so we
were able to
split the westwood home marshalls
between biddeford and turret
biddeford and westwood hill which was i
think useful
um the scheme launched in mid july as i
mentioned and we only had
approximately 10 days really and to put
the schemes together to
to do to design them from scratch really
um we ended up partnering with with a
company called red elephant security
from south melton who
i must say we're extremely um
professional
and reliable and and were really a
useful asset to us
and we were delighted to receive funding
which meant we could employ two marshals
per
town per village or town um for nine
hours a day
and they worked right up until
mid-september so we had a presence
on the ground um every day um for
a month and a half nearly two months
in that time uh the marshals from red
elephant dealt with
that uh 325 incidents across the the
sites
and it it rains from all kinds of things
that range from dog fouling
um to children separate by from the
parents
um to first aid with an overarching
theme of
keeping people safe um and promoting the
idea of
social distancing hands face spaces as
people more important than me
like to say um every day we had
thing a virtual meeting um every morning
at nine o'clock
apart from sundays we gave us we gave
ourselves some days off but so monday to
saturday
we had a meeting where we could talk
about um
the previous day's events and anything
that was
likely to come acro come up over the
next uh of the next day
um we kept an eye on the weather for
example which might suggest that we have
more
more visitors it worked really well i
think um
the feedback we received from both um
the
uh both the the venues the villages
themselves
and the public in those villages were
really good really promising
um the the police and crime commissioner
actually running um
an evaluation exercise as we speak and
we look forward to getting the
the full results from that my personal
opinion i think that
regardless of um covered restrictions or
anything
uh and touchwood they won't be in place
next summer
um they were useful to have it
in our um coastal resorts i think they
were it was a really positive experience
now i'd like to move on to our
involvement in the
adolescent safety framework
this is a program that's um designed and
run by
children social care
and it's designed to support children
children young people
um across across across devon
um that are at risk of at risk
by risks identified outside of the
family home
so it's designed to the the process is
designed to put the young person
as the focus of the um of any um
action taken and it's really important
that all the agencies um work together
to make sure that children are safe
outside of the family home and this is
where we fit in
we obviously have local knowledge um of
our
uh our areas and our environments
and therefore we are i've been tasked
with
when these um when conferences are
arranged
to deal with conferences that are around
neighborhoods so it's
um issues that present themselves in
particular neighborhoods
so for example if there was a park where
children it was felt that children were
safe
were unsafe in our area that was where
we where we would get involved
we were involved right at the outset of
this of this new scheme this new proceed
these new procedures
and we helped to shape how they might
look um
both myself and dean and others have
received training
um about uh how these conferences will
be
uh undertaken and how important is to
get
um that partnership basis um for any
decision
made now as i think uh as we mentioned
previous
previously in these presentations we're
used to working in partnership
we absolutely see the real
benefits of it and i think that if we
can bring out
our knowledge and our ability to work in
partnership to this this area where
you know at the end of the day it's
about keeping children safe
in our communities then that can only be
a positive for us and
it's it's um it
it feels really good to be able to
contribute to that really important work
lastly i'm going to talk about our
trauma conference um that again has been
mentioned very
briefly by adina a moment ago
so in
uh january 2020 we delivered a
conference at philly village
and it was about trauma-informed care
so we looked at how
trauma can affect young people
um both physically and mentally and what
how
that might make them act either in their
age group or in later life
and really how we as practitioners
should be able to should treat people
who have had
um a traumatic life which will
inevitably affect well
it will if it may well affect their
behavior
as i mentioned the event was held at
fiddly with at all um
i think we had 150 plus delegates
i mean it really was standing room only
um
but the the energy i think the
enthusiasm in the room that we got from
everybody
who who attended from a very wide
array of agencies um was
was really positive it was really
positive but four
outstanding presentations from various
um
people um someone who had lived
experience of trauma
in their youth and how they have managed
to um deal with that
uh was was particularly inspirational um
yeah i because i'd say it was a really
fascinating insight into
the work that we are doing and can do in
the future
and then unfortunately we went into
lockdown
um in march this year so
that put our work back a bit but we are
absolutely determined not to lose any
momentum that
that we've built up through through the
conference um
and we'll shortly be unveiling further
training that we will give to
practitioners
about practical measures that they can
take to make sure that um
people's experience of trauma are um
people's
experience people who have experienced
trauma are treated
um in a way that can help them um by us
all
i think there's lots of work about
trauma-informed approaches going on
across devon in the uk and it feels to
me that um
we're ahead of the game really you know
we're well on the way to
um putting these important concepts
into the work we do so um we will of
course continue to do that
um and see where that takes us
and that's the end of my presentation
for today thank you
thank you very much tim
sorry can i just come in conclude
i i'd like you now tim to uh toby sorry
to sum up what you want to sum up i will
then take questions
from north devon district councillors
and then i'll hand over to councillor
pennington who will then uh take
questions
to you or whoever from uh from
uh torridge district councillors so uh
first of all with yourself toby please
never i wait with baited breath um no
parts at all so
the uh just to say for the next year
clearly
um the impacts the covid and the cobra
impacts are gonna
cover off uh much of what we do but if i
could just first of all thank
the presentations from those who just
done it because it's not easy on zoom
having done it so my thanks those just
provided the updates from the team
next year some of the areas are focused
firstly
the changes around how we get funding
from the opcc i think there's some
really good reasons behind why that's
going to happen
um but we need to understand that
quickly and get ahead of the game
because i want to make sure that north
devon torres can get a really big
um bite uh of the uh of the money that
is
uh available and if we don't get ahead
of that and understand that quickly
uh we might miss the boat so that's
number one
secondly it's been talked about already
trauma informed high intensity
in essence i'm quite passionate about we
don't want to keep the same people
coming back to the door
a lot of this is the same people coming
back to all of us all our services
and if we don't address their underlying
issues
it's just the same old cycle so really
keen that we understand
things uh better and we provide more
focus and awareness around that
the other area that i'm really keen on
that we pick up is
our morality i think it defines us as an
area
and there there is a unique kind of
isolation and feeling of vulnerability
you get from living in the morality and
i'm really keen that as a partnership we
kind of think about our response there
is a perception
that stuff gets sucked into the urban
centers and we need to just be ensured
that we're covering what really defines
us as an area
and finally i really want to change the
narrative
to be a lot more positive talk
because we have spent the last few years
talking about austerity and lots of
things about what we can't do
uh but actually there's so much
excellent superb work going in
going in and on around north devon
torrid so i want to celebrate that
and promote that and really keen
yourself as elected members that are
here today as well that we use that
as a platform to celebrate actually what
a great job we're all doing and what a
fantastic area that we live in as i've
said before one of the safest
in the country so um inc that's
that's me concluded joe so i shall hand
it back
over to you as as chair thank you very
much toby
uh on behalf of north devon district
council
um could i thank you and your
in the offices present today um
and uh the part
work that is being done uh within our
area
um and thank you very much for that
comprehensive uh
report i'm sure councillor pennington
will want to add something at
the end of his question time on the
subject but uh thank you very much i
agree with you kaiser tucker
to save time absolutely agree with that
sentiment thank you
uh so uh orianna
i haven't got on my screen um
a hand for any any hands that go up
so could you tell me uh the north devon
district councillors please who want to
ask a question
but before they do i'd just like to uh
come back to you toby please
and that is just to say that i think
it's more of a statement rather than a
question but
um the the fantastic work
that you and your officers and staff are
doing and maybe
right throughout the country on this
county lines drug
uh business because this is uh
something that we are approached by
members of the public who have got great
concerns
on the drug problem that is coming out
of these uh
these bigger cities and it does appear
in some of these bigger cities that
it's nearly out of control but perhaps
if toby if you'd like to just
make a comment on that but uh it's just
that
it looks as if you're on top of the top
of the system so
just a brief comment from you toby on
that and then i'll go to orianna
to see if we've got any questions from
north dam district
yeah joe no i appreciate that and the
thanks i say is not just to the police
it is to the partnership um
our intelligence department reports that
north devon and torridge provide more
intel than any other area
in the force and you can only act on
what you know so we don't know what's
there until people tell us and the
housing officer that spots
the cocoon uh the like uh i would say
probably one of the
highlights the last three years if you
went and asked an elected member three
or four years ago what counted lines was
i suspect none of us would have known uh
a handful but
the the level of knowledge has helped
and the
the activity towards it now is
and and the the difference it's made is
is significant
there was a moment probably a few months
ago well the first time i think i've
heard this
where there was there was no reported
county lines group
in our area at all now when one goes you
tend to get three or four come
come back in off the back of it so we
have to keep on it all the time but we
are making it
massively unattractive to come down here
we're not easy pickings
we're not the rural backdrop which some
of the uh the city folk may have thought
they were going to be targeting they
they come down here
they're going to feel the full force of
the local force and the partnership so
we will keep we'll keep that momentum
going so thank you joe
thank you very much toby i have a
question now from counselor
uh liz bullin please
hi um can you hear me
we can hear you but can't see you i i
can't get i can't get my picture up
no we can hear you that's okay okay
right um
just a question please i'm very pleased
to hear what's been done on county lines
that's really good news
can i ask a question what has been done
about rural
crime because it's on the increase it
appears um
farmers are having more tele-handlers
and gps systems stolen and things
what are our local officers doing to try
and um
negate this please tell me back to you
yeah so i've got to keep pressing my um
the button uh yeah no
i i think i just uh eluded that at the
end
i'm very aware that there's a danger
when we look at threat harm and risk it
sometimes it can concentrate you to
areas which you may not perceive to
address some of the issues and the
morality
i don't think we've got an increase in
rural crime but there is definitely
a uniqueness and there's particular
vulnerability to morality and as you
as you alluded to there's certain crime
types we're more susceptible to
so we have a we have a rural crime team
uh across the force who put out a lot
campaigns awareness and prevention work
uh and as i said as a partnership i'm
really keen to understand what we can do
here locally as well to provide that
we've got to be smart about how we
identify the support we can give
from reality we haven't got the resource
we may have had in the past but we need
to be clever about how we use the
resource that we have got
so there's a lot of work at the moment
to ensure that the resources that we got
within the police i'm sure the parts are
exactly the same
that they're protect given the time and
space to do the work that they're
supposed to be doing
and not getting sucked into some of the
uh those
those urban issues so no very aware of
it and
we are there is in time we're looking
for volunteers elected members would be
very welcome
uh to get involved in a uh some activity
in the partnership about how we could
better
better provide and recognize that
morality so one of my
officers problem solvers is going to be
leading on that and doing it
across devon so we will come back to you
and and put out an invite for those that
might like to get involved and sort of
um
have your voice heard thank you toby and
thank you councillor bullet orianna i
haven't got any
other hands on myself yes okay chair yes
we have council liz spear
followed by councillor julie hunt thank
you
carry on is it captioning
me carry on this
thank you chair um very briefly um i
know i've already spoken to tim on this
and he'll
guess what i'm going to say the street
marshals
that um operated in mullicom and croyd
um i know there was a brilliant um
result
came out of that and i know this is kobe
related
and that and we all know that's not
going to go away very quickly
um if resources allow
um because in braunton we have had
and i understand it is covet related we
have had a lot of problems the last few
months
with antisocial behavior not just
drinking and drugs but a lot of
vandalism major vandalism in the village
which we have reported
if resources allow i'd like to make sure
that uh braunton is registered that
we would like to have if resources allow
some patrols please if if this beca if
this system becomes available again next
year
thank you chair thank you back to you
toby or tim whichever
tim do you want to answer that i mean
there is some more funding coming
liz um the opcc funded that and that
money's been used up
but there has been more money as you
probably knows from central government
has come back
to support enforcement and um
the education and encouraging people to
to meet the
the covid guidance so um tim
you do you want to come in
yeah the only thing i'd like to say i
think i mentioned in the presentation
that um
uh we it was prescribed what areas that
we we had to
put the marshals in however
you know we know uh through our
experience and
um through conversations we had during
the summer that
that there were other areas that were
affected
uh and continue to be affected by
anti-social behavior
um i think the um marshall's
uh scheme helped that um but you know
and
we put in our evaluation to um the pcc
that
there are other areas that would need uh
that could benefit from such an
approach and and i would hope that if
and when
the scheme is extended that we would
have more say about where the marshals
are deployed because it it makes sense
to me that it should be
the local area where who can identify
where the bigger
issues are thank you tim
just to reassure you sorry um
sorry it goes up slow joe it goes over
and above
um the the marshals are over and above
our activity
uh we've given out uh hundreds upon
hundreds of
uh of what we call the three e's where
we've you've encouraged
uh i explained people to to to to meet
the guidance
at the same time we sadly where there's
been flagrant
blades and breaches we've also given out
a number of tickets i've got the figures
i think we're around
60 or 70 tickets that we've uh we've
also been
dished out to people who've ignored that
stuff so that stuff's still happening
and braunton's no exception so
my officers are very clear on the
direction that they're given and they
are out about
dealing so please pass it through your
local team as well
thank you toby councillor julie hunt and
then councillor robbie mack please
yes
thank you thank you chair thank you
chair um
it's a bit of a two-part question really
um obviously have they seen in an inc
how much of an increase have they seen
in the amount of scam
that's going around um and and the
reason i'm asking is how are we going to
get this
to the general public to know what to
look for because
i noticed quite a few coming through on
my emails
and um a couple been quite newish ones
they're
quite good ones as well i've had to do a
double tape before i realized they were
a scam because
they seem to be getting better and
better at it if you know what i mean
joe can i uh can not is knoll uh able to
come on that i know some good work
around
cybercrime noel are you able to answer
that one
yeah absolutely so um yeah as i
mentioned earlier
um we did there has been an increase and
nationally uh we've seen a 66 percent
increase in this type of uh fraud um
and there's two reasons for that one is
because people sat at home
for longer um and the other reason is
because the more vulnerable people are
sat at home
for for longer as well and that's
generally age-related as well
so and the reason why i know them facts
is because we had our
our first cyber uh fraud um
commute uh community bite size input on
on teams uh last or two weeks ago um
and we we brought up our cyber unit so
we have all the experts who can educate
people
and education really is the key to to
prevent this because rather like you
two weeks ago i was very close to buying
a stand-up board
and it was only when i got to putting in
my details and this is a police officer
with experience
a lot of experience of of crime
investigation
and i even i was almost defrauded to the
point where
it was when i was in the drop down box
for areas the united kingdom was spelt
wrong
and that for me sent the flag up and i
stopped at that point and i was only
several clicks away from purchasing
something um
but education really is the key because
this is a
a an international problem predominantly
the people who are targeting
our community are not people within the
uk they're people on an international
level
um on a an industrial level as well so
in countries like nigeria and various
other countries
there are people who turn up to work
every day in large offices
in organized offices and their soul
their sole enterprise during that day is
to to contact people via the internet
or via telephones to try and scam people
so
me um clearly not in my my younger years
but i'm not at the age where i may have
just clicked and made them additional
clicks
um but we've we've been working now i
started on up jessica in 2015
uh and it really was about education
going out to the to the communities
going out to village halls and and
really educating people
our community uh crime prevention
officer kim foster now does that
and she was more than happy to go and
vis visit village halls and do that
face-to-face
obviously with the advent of kovi that's
that's been uh
difficult to deliver um so we're now
going on on a
a platform rather like this i would uh
encourage uh when the ad when you see
the adverts go out on facebook and
various other
means please do get out your members to
your community and tell them to
actively go on air to family members who
have got concerns about
elderly family members or vulnerable
people again bring them into that room
show them uh what we're delivering and
for me that's key to it all because
clearly trying to prevent someone doing
something
internationally is going to always be a
problem for us
thank you is there is there is there's
some way we can have like a
leaflet that we can actually especially
the elderly that aren't on social media
and that
in our um like because i'm in a rural
area you know in our villages and
whatnot that we can
actually actually deliver to them to
make them aware
absolutely i'll take an action away
today julie and i will ask kim foster
uh to to request more leaflets we have
avoided leaflets over the last
several months for obvious reasons but
it's a valid point and i'll ask him to
uh
to request more leaflets and we'll have
them available if you all wanted to
email me my email details are on there
with a request for a specific area then
we can get them delivered out as well
lovely thank you so much if you could
email that please to
the clerks of this committee they can
email it out then to the members who are
listening in
or to all members within the within the
council
uh robbie mack please
yes um it's great to hear about all of
the the
uh stuff going on around anti-social
behavior i attended a
very good meeting yesterday with tim
whistle and others about anti-social
behavior in the town center and
hoping the pspo on the
full council agenda north devon council
tonight goes some way to helping to
tackle that
um it's sort of related to antisocial
but well the question is is it related
to anti-social behavior the
the serious crimes that we've had lately
in basketball there have been a few
stabbings um over recent months maybe
a bit longer than that um i'm just
wondering how much of that is felt that
is spilling out from anti-social
behavior that maybe wasn't
um you know uh dealt with in
quick enough and how much was just
completely unrelated and if there's any
um police strategy to deal with these
you know serious
uh threatening stabbings because i know
that a few residents in basketball are
actually
getting quite afraid of certain areas
whether whether it's safer than the rest
of the country i'm sure we are i'm glad
about that
it still goes into people's mindsets i
i can answer that joe and i of course i
i totally get
that that's going to leave an impact on
certain communities
i would say as you kind of alluded to
actually the levels of crime still
exceptionally low
but doesn't mean we're immune to the odd
uh examples of a very serious uh so the
ones you're referring to
in honesty it's drug related i wouldn't
suggest it's necessarily
uh town center asb the discussions
you've been having with tim and others
uh slightly different uh cohort that
makes sense more alcohol related
this is more drug uh drug related so uh
what we have got is we've got an
incredibly professional team
of detectives behind and i alluded to
earlier on our outcome rate is
exceptionally high we have a very
good turnover of actually finding out
who's responsible and ensuring those
individuals
face justice uh and disappear which
obviously then goes to fulfill our
prophecy of maintaining the um the
safety in our area so
i wouldn't say directly asb you're
talking about robbie but
but um but we are we are in a fortunate
position that when we do have the more
serious
matters and let's not pretend we have a
lot of serious
uh crimes racist crimes across our area
that still occur
um we clearly we dedicate more resource
and more time to those those particular
jobs understandably
no apology uh from that front but um
that's probably as much as i can say on
that without
talking about the specific if you know
what i'm saying because i can't do that
because it's still obviously
we call subjudicine still subjective
investigation thank you toby
thank you um orianna i have a hat
one hand up who is that please
is it sergeant orc i'm not sure it's the
galaxy a5
yeah galaxy a5 please yeah that's me uh
yeah just to echo the uh
the uh sentiments of of superintendent
davis in terms of the asb
um i chair the asb steering group it's
it's in its infancy
we've only had two meetings now but we
certainly do recognize the real value in
get
getting in early so it doesn't escalate
into some of the issues we've
encountered in both torridge
and barnstable over the summer our data
supports there has been an increase
and it generally happens over the summer
period which will come as no surprise
because people are out
during the more clement whether the
knights are longer
uh but now in recognition of that we
have the asb steering group we've also
now
drafted up uh the two pspos which have
additional powers in
so now we talk about um any
any any um matters which uh there are
gatherings of people so we can disperse
people
uh where we we anticipate there's likely
to be an escalation of asp
we recognize and we know the people
responsible for this
so having that power uh hopefully
supported by the ball council meetings
in both torridge and north then will
enable us to get in early
but we do recognize actually we need to
get in earlier for the asb so we don't
find ourselves back to where we've been
over the last few summer months thank
you very much for that
orianna i think we've taken up quite a
considerable amount of time
uh on our questions and i think it's but
i don't think there's any more
that want to ask a question is there not
i can see chair no you're quite right
right well before i uh hand over to
councillor pennington
just to recap uh toby to thank you
and all your staff and the partnership
uh
for all the excellent work you're doing
and keep up the good work thank you very
much over to councillor pennington
please
thank you councillor chair tucker and we
will now go through the same motions on
the torrid side i'm looking for any
questions
from either the torch members of
committee or the torch counselors
attending the meeting
i have the first blue hand and that's
counselor harding
please ask your question thank you chair
um
yeah well it's great to hear that um
there's a great positivity not from um
toby davis and all the teams and it is
great to hear that you know
things are moving on it i was just
wondering um
basically it's close to my heart because
i've been
um in trouble with this um mental health
and there's a lot of businesses going
down now with the
culvert and there's a lot of people
losing their jobs
and is there enough help out there
um for this mental health because the
police are always the first point men
and first people in line to see it and
is there is there enough
help behind there is there enough
funding i was just wondering
what situation we are
uh is there an answer from any of the
csp team
uh uh so i can come in um i'm happy if
any of the toys want to come in as well
then then let me know
okay so so do you feel there's enough
funding as i think councillor harding's
question
yeah yeah yeah i i'm going to be
diplomatic
on this front in honesty as well i mean
to be clear as from a csp perspective
partnership mental health clearly uh has
a big demand and a big impact on on a
lot of what we do but
in fairness it's such a broad theme it's
picked up
in in other forums and there's a load of
brilliant work going on
in terms of we've got a uh i think
knolls alluded to the high intensity
partnership there's the subsequent
crisis cafes
we've got street triage that do work
with people in crisis
on the ground and we can talk to nurses
on the phone
um you've seen some great work from the
district councils and highways and
county around designing artwork on both
the bridges
i know that uh janet williams i think
she's online at sits as part of the
suicide prevention alliance uh and some
work that's that's going on
that said i'm not going to pretend uh
that there are some issues uh
clearly our suicide rate uh would
from what i've seen in in recent times
is higher than i think we would like
uh uh in terms of the numbers of those
people
in crisis the available service up here
is
isn't is it brilliant so we have to do a
lot of work all those things suggested
to kind of
to to compensate for that so it's it's a
big it's a big challenge for policing
and the partnership because most of
people we come into contact with
particularly those high intensity users
mental health will uh will be a an area
of of concern so we are working hard
with partners and other groups um
and health to to to see what we can do
and provide as much support as we
possibly can
and i guess it sounds like the elected
member who just raised the questions i
think
uh catch the uh the name as is
they may be involved in that so i i
don't know is janet on the line
just around the suicide prevention work
janet
yep i'm here toby i'm here chair um
yes uh i am the uh csp representative
on the um devon suicide strategic group
this is quite a new group
and that's been set up there is a a
devon
uh suicide strategy and that is
currently being refreshed
and it's it's uh it's an area that
there is a lot going on obviously the
health services are very involved in
that group
and what we're trying to do at the
moment is really and try and tease out
what part of that that overall project
that we can really
get behind and make a difference um
locally in northern devon
so it's very much works in progress at
the at the moment
and it's totally mentioned and i think
just sort of mirroring
um sort of national reports and concerns
and there is a lot of concern about um
about mental health
and um that generally um
we believe that the the suicide rate is
is is going up
and but we're still trying to um get
real-time numbers down in in devon
to see where the the areas of biggest
risk
are and there's a there's a project
that's that's going on at the moment
and that's been led by county whether um
there is um surveillance of um all
reported suicides in in devon previously
and there was quite a slow process of
getting that data because it had to go
through the corridor or
and through the through the formal
processes to actually determine whether
um a death was a was a suicide we're
trying to get that
information a lot more quickly now and
so that we can be a lot more
effective in where um help is is being
targeted so
it's certainly something that's on the
radar and it's certainly something that
we feel as a csp
we need to have a better better handle
on and be more involved with in the
in the future um but as i say is it's
something that's works in progress at
the at the current time
thank you is satisfy the answers
councillor harding
yes thank you chair um i'll just uh like
i say i i lost my business and i know
how deep and black the whole is
and uh you know with the businesses
going down now and um
and the way that uh you know life is
where you
you know you are restricted of things i
just feel that you know
it is it is going to be a busy time
in the near future and uh you know i
wish everybody well and uh if there's
anything i could do i would love to help
but uh
um like i say i think it's uh it's gonna
be
testing times thank you thank you um
counselor laws you've been waiting a
long time a very
contributor to this uh meeting and uh
your question
counselor laws yes no don't worry about
the time i find it all exceedingly
interesting and i think it's
an excellent joint presentation here
um my question uh i'm um district
councillor for westwood ho
uh this summer i mean we've had an
amazing summer it's been
so busy my own house i looked down
across the green at westwood ho
and this summer i could barely see the
grass
now the thing my question is based
around the street marshals
absolutely excellent they uh
were walking through the green and they
were speaking to
groups of people and obviously
explaining social distancing to them etc
my question is um is there any way of
measuring
um the effect they have because
we've had by my my
sort of knowledge is terribly limited
but we seem to have had a very
peaceful summer down here uh and at
times in the past it's been
not peaceful um do you think
two questions do you think the marshalls
it's been as successful as i think
and is there any way of measuring
figures for general crime
uh over their period again shall we say
last year
thank you chair i i will uh hand you
across
to um to dean a minute i would say there
has been evaluation
uh the feedback has been uh very
positive there has been elements
um and i think liz raised north devon
district side
actually we could perhaps consider some
other areas as well it was we had no
control over the areas
where that money came to and and i will
feedback the pcc
your really positive comments um and
uh dean is it yourself best place to
answer that answer that with regard to
street marshals
yes i can certainly pick that one
october
yeah good afternoon claims to the laws
yeah i mean just to clarify as uh toby's
already uh
intimated unfortunately we didn't have
any say
uh on the actual areas that we could
deliver this program
but obviously we were keen not only to
have it in biddeford
but we did push that boundary to include
westwood her as well
as obviously it's a seaside resort and
we knew that you would get a high
um footfall of um holidaymakers during
the summer
and you're right the the outcomes from
the street marshals
were phenomenal and obviously the daily
meetings we had
the feedback not only from the company
but also from our
and from the public was outstanding and
like you say
there was some very very incidents
reported
now obviously i don't have any data in
front of me uh in relation to 2019 to
compare that to 2020
but having been in this role for a
number of years i hope
i have historically dealt with quite a
lot of anti-social behavior issues
uh in westwood ho during our peaks on a
season
and i have to say that this year was
probably the only year
that i haven't dealt with any
individuals
in westwood hope for any and social
behavior reported issues
so that's unprecedented for us as a
partnership
dealing with asb in the community
obviously we have had issues
in biddeford town center during the
summer season but certainly
considering the footfall that we had
during the summer
um we've had no reported incidents as
far as i'm aware
obviously i haven't got any crime dated
to hand so i can give you any
crime comparison data but just to say
that because we had those daily meetings
with the group
we were able to quite easily coordinate
them
around weather conditions and around any
intelligence that we had
to ensure that they engaged and dealt
with the public
quite proactively and i think that
showed uh council laws
in the fact that we had a really good
um profitable and really good calm
summer
if i could be a little tiki chair um i
would just raise the funding is one off
uh and it might come in again with a
little bit more cobia
might allow some some opportunity around
the street marshals but
i think what it does show for a more
sustainable future around asb
is the benefit of having those
individuals who can concentrate on
nothing but that
um and as a local authority and as a
partnership
it may be we might want to be discussing
this going forward
into summer 2021 and onwards whether we
want to have those powers or those
individuals
to to to be there these are perhaps
somewhere more
problematic locations just to keep that
peace
so um not a discussion for now but maybe
a discussion
in the next few months um because
it is as i say it's only one off funding
that's making it happen now but if you
want to carry that
carry that on as a more sustainable
solution we might
need to we'll work um how we can fund it
uh lord kosher laws you seem like you're
behaving yourself this summer compared
to last summer
i would just like to say thank you and
of course i know it's a bit
cheeky but these street marshals have
proved what the general public
are saying and requesting all the time
your presence is very valuable
the more you're seen on the streets
whether it's street marshals or your
officers
the better thank you very much indeed
thank you council laws for your question
councillor cottle hunken
hi thank you um there's mention in the
report about
delivering a programme of youth
engagement within biddeford
i was which is brilliant i was just
wondering about other areas within
torridge
i'm a ward member for great torrington
and i know that
youth engagement would be really
welcomed there we've got a small amount
but
we definitely need more and secondly the
community triggers
it said that there were four activations
but all four didn't meet the local
threshold
i was just wondering if you could give
some examples and tell us what that
means because
what is the local threshold please
um can i chair can i again i'll try to
put on the spot again because there's no
way i can do it in this um
in zoom and
janet you might want to comment on the
youth engagement but dean you've
obviously reviewed those triggers do you
want to explain those first
yes certainly toby yeah thank you uh
council for couple hundred
um obviously i'm the um csp lead for
choice issue council
so all those community triggers that are
activated uh they do come into me to
review
um and it's quite funny that an
incidental that uh
the all the triggers that we've had as a
partnership um
i've all been in in the torrenton area
um
so you're probably familiar or aware of
some of the issues that have been
ongoing
but just to give you an idea of what the
threshold
is locally it's set um as a devon
threshold
and those are three reports of
anti-social behavior
to one organization within the preceding
six months
so that's what's called the trigger
activation
so for instance if there's a member of
the community
that have reported three or more
incidents of asp
to a single authority and that single
authority might be local authority
in their environmental health setting or
it could be police
and then obviously those reports are
looked at and reviewed
and in the incidents that we had under
the four reviews
and there were only crimes that had been
reported
that were not associated with
anti-social behavior
and in one of the situations that in
fact there were no reports
of anti-social behavior having been
reported
to any organization whatsoever so hence
why the triggers were
negative and didn't meet the threshold
but that's not to say that we haven't
engaged
with the people that activated those
triggers what i did as part of the
process
and i gave them some additional uh sign
posting to different agencies
that could potentially support them and
i've given them
officer details both in local authority
and with regard to police so that they
can be helped
should they um end up being victim of
any and social behavior going forward
so there have been signposted and they
have been dealt with
and i think that shows testament that um
obviously on those four occasions
with all the triggers there wasn't one
of those triggers that was appealed with
the office and police
crime commissioner so that's positive
are you happy with that answer
councillor cottle hunkin yeah thank you
for that
okay would you would you like me to
cover the um
youth engagement chair yes there was a
second part to council hotel hunting's
uh
question um very simply put cancer
cottle honking it's
um the the youth engagement um and
outreach is is really one of the tools
that we have to deal with with
anti-social behavior
in the in the community so where we have
uh defined issues
um in in any area and certainly when
it's youth related
the um the the the youth outreach
tends to be our first port of call we
don't want to criminalize
uh young people and you know they're
normally causing
um antisocial behavior for it for a
reason it's it's normally boredom
and so really we engage with with a
number of organizations typically
and space and to um to carry out that
that
outreach and engagement function to try
and nip the the problem in the bud
in a in a positive um and an effective
way
and so all i'll say is if we've not done
that in in torrington it's probably
because we haven't
had any issues raised with us but if
there are problems please contact us
and as i say it's something that we can
we can arrange for for torrington
if the need is there chair can i just
ask
noel just to give a little bit on the
mini police um because that might be an
opportunity there for
the council with regards torrington
yes please then no well though um yeah
just in relation to the asb
as well we've had um operation mano
running which was three thousand pound
for a an organization called space there
basically an outreach um group based in
um
the headquarters is in exeter but they
cover the whole of devon
so they have been doing targeted
outreach in torrington
um as a result of the money dean's
probably not
being a bit modest here actually dean
was responsible for
forgetting that funding and implementing
that so there would have been space
workers out within torrington
uh we have bid for additional funding
for five thousand pound
for torridge barnstable and west devon
uh
for more of this type of work so if
there is uh ongoing asb
then we hopefully be successful in that
bid and we will target
those resources to to to the relevant
areas
in terms of mini policing um we now have
a dedicated police officer
as of last month he is now responsible
for rolling out mini police
which is junior school age
junior cadets which is ages 11 to 13
and senior cadets which is 13 up to 18
and they are police cadets so within the
mini police we've had we've uh
sent correspondence out to all 88
primary schools
within the whole of north and west devon
uh asking for
uh the ability to go into the schools
and deliver a six-week program
uh of an hour input by a police officer
to years five and six
so uh ages 10 and 11 and it will be a
six week program
delivering by the end of that six week
program a a targeted response to
an an issue within their area so it
could be littering speeding and so on
and so forth
but it's at an early age encouraging
engagement with with police building up
trust with police
but also encouraging those to be more
community-minded at that age
and the long-term plan was will be
hopefully to sustain a model working
towards
the the cadet scheme as well which will
be an evening
uh a week over school term where again
police will deliver
a cadet program uh for people so
hopefully it'll be a diversion
away from that asb and something which
will be a real positive in all of the in
all of the communities we haven't had
all the schools respond
we're currently starting in january in
four schools
uh those who've responded immediately
but all schools haven't so again
if i could a request to all all elected
members
if you do have contacts within the
school can you ask them please to
respond to us
because we're keen to get that program
out sooner rather than later
thank you right
we have coached the leather please
thank you chad yeah i'm very interested
listening to uh
the questions and the presentations that
that's been given this afternoon
um i just wonder with the membership of
the community safety partnership and i
didn't mention it last year
when we had this meeting the quarterly
meetings that happened
how often other members of this
partnership attend because
i'm not sure the partnership's working a
hundred percent because
as has been mentioned this the uh
marshalls that happened in westminster
and biddeford
uh during the summer that money came
from the police and crown commissioners
office
but as um superintendent davis has said
there was no
discussion with the police of where it
would be best to use that money and
where these marshals
would be more effective so i just wonder
you know
is that partnership working as well as
it could do if if
one part of it goes off and does
something on its own without reference
to anybody else
and the same really i would say with the
with the local health authority really
with and
councillor harding has mentioned mental
health
issues the girl on biddeford bridge i
don't think it's biddeford bridge
uh superintendent davis was alluding to
or the torridge high level bridge but
whichever bridge
it was an ongoing thing that kept
reoccurring and reoccurring
and reoccurring and all these uh
various bodies were put to a lot of
effort to try and deal with it
it seemed to take an awful long time
from how he explained it until
eventually i think he said she was more
or less
told she was just being a nuisance or
causing problem
whether it was mental health it wasn't
made clear but it seemed that was a
repeat thing
that was causing a lot of problems and
it wasn't dealt with
very quickly and again in the report
okay i would have liked some case
studies and i think
um councillor cottle hunkins has touched
on that because
i'd highlight lighted these uh
community trigger activations now i
wonder if the public know
about this enough whether they think
well this is
this is anti-social behavior i'm going
to ring up and
report it nothing gets done so they drop
it then
they think well it's a waste of time
nobody's nobody's doing anything about
it do they know they've got to make
these three reports within six months
on anti-social behavior um but
dean dill explained about the four in
the torridge district which happened to
be in torrington area
but again a case study
would be good in the next bit that
really does
interest and concern me is the devin
children and family partnership
joint delivery of the adolescent safety
framework program
and the paragraph in there i've
highlighted is
this pathway is designed to maximize the
participation
of the young person to focus on the
situation
how the situation can be made safer i
would have liked
a case study in there of how this an
example of how this actually works
just to state what you know it does go
on to mention
peer groups blah blah blah i'd like a
case study there
i mean you reject obviously the names of
anybody involved you can make it
obscure enough so nobody could be
identified but i really would like a
case study
so we can see the progression of how
that would work
um and i think the bottom one on page 18
they're about
street attached people street attached
i think we're probably talking about
street drinkers and rough sleepers
possibly there and druggies as well drug
addicts
um but finally something that i always
bring up because it's true
no matter talking about this being a
safe area in northern devon and devon in
general
compared with other parts of the country
i'm not interested in other parts of the
country
and the people who live down here are
only interested in what's happening in
this area
and it is true in this area that violent
crime
is on the increase violent crime with or
without injury
to the person is on the increase and i
gave some examples
about six or eight weeks ago at northern
town council police figures that i've
got
so you know whilst we are a safe area
compared to some
areas in this country violent crime
still is on the increase which is
very sad thank you chair
uh i wonder which of our officers would
like to respond to some of the things
well i i'll i'll try and break break it
down uh first of all the feedback loaded
on the uh
on the report so we'll we'll review that
and note that
uh there's a recorded meeting so we'll
capture some of that feedback
i would just reassure um let's remember
that
some of his colleagues elected members
sit on the partnership so those members
are there
and they offer as as as part of their
role
at accountability elect accountability
uh throughout the year as well
um i'll see phil hackett for your for
your side the house
in relation to the funding
is on the line today he's listening to
this meeting by the way
i thought i'm sure i'm sure he i'm sure
he was so uh welcome phil
the uh the funding from the pcc uh for
the street marshals
she gave uh 500 000 she gave it across
she did
she determined uh with some uh some data
to back it up
the areas where she wanted to put that
money ultimately it's her money
uh what we were able to do as a
partnership
is influence that because it wasn't the
the areas that we've been that we
actually
were covered uh changed because we were
able to
uh offer some some feedback from a
partnership or two as to
including westwood ho uh and ultimately
on the north devon district side
including ilfracombe
uh town central harbour so we had an
opportunity to influence
in terms of the theme on the bridge it
wasn't me that raised that that would
have been knoll
and i think noel was referring to that
very issue the repeat issue of people
going back to the same location
we've got a partnership program called
the high intensity pilot which is
changing our response so we don't keep
going back and we look to try and find
a resolution to it i don't think it'd be
um
appropriate to go through the community
triggers in detail
here specifically um i didn't capture
because quite a lot in there
in honesty in terms of questions so uh
janet or dean is there anything that you
wanted to add to
any of those comments observations from
council leather
i can call you a chair if you'd like
in relation to the community triggers i
know council leather raised some issues
around that
yes please uh dean if you can respond
yeah thank you chair uh councillor
leather yeah just to confirm
uh in relation to any victims that we
deal with on a day-to-day basis
who are suffering from antisocial
behaviour in the community
obviously we are able to monitor them
quite carefully so i work quite closely
with localhood neighbourhood uh big
teams and policing teams in
holdsworthy torrington and biddeford so
we were able to identify
any persistent victims in our
communities and obviously
if they're talking to us and they feel
that they are victim of asv
then obviously we can signpost them and
we do sign post them
to the community trigger program uh
which is run
by uh devon cornwall police and all
triggers are logged
via 101 and then the victim has a set
pro forma
that they fill out and then it comes
into the community safety partnership to
action
so we are engaging with victims on a
day-to-day basis
and we always we are signposting them
should we feel that potentially
uh they could warrant a community
trigger activation
and i hope that answers the question in
relation uh to your concerns about the
trigger
thank you dean and janet uh would you
like to
you were going to make a response just
now before dean
thank you well i was i wasn't mentioning
about the community triggers but but
dean's covered that the only thing i
would say is that um
absolutely we think we can include some
um
case studies um in future reports either
on this
um annual process or we can try and get
something into
the uh the member briefings um as and
when things go up
and try and um raise the the the profile
and understanding of all the members
um of um the various um bits of
of work of the the community safety team
and what we're involved in
um i think for the for the report this
uh the annual report we try and make it
as
efficient as possible i wouldn't say
short there's a lot to
to put in but uh we do have to uh
try and um maintain some gravity on the
uh
on the reports because we don't want to
overwhelm members but that's certainly
something that we can
we can take for uh for future reports
thank you and chair just a final uh
closing comment violent crime as a whole
is down for this area uh i can't count
leather may be looking for some um
particular stats
for the area that he covers like i can't
answer that in honesty i haven't got
those in
front of me but what i would say is i'll
make no apology for this
i will talk very positively about uh
how safe we are and the crime levels
because sometimes
uh one of the greatest issues i've
experienced around here is perceptions
of crime
the fear of crime is is higher than the
reality
and so it's really important for me that
i that we draw out those positives and
celebrate the success of what we are
doing really well at
because that then feeds into reassuring
our our community so i will always be
positive
about how we are nationally in
comparison to other areas
council another are you happy with the
responses or do you want to make a
further
well as far as violent crime goes only
to say that
does the report it just talk about
reporting
crime and we do know a lot of people
don't bother reporting any crime now
because they don't feel they're going to
get it's going to get dealt with in
indeed in some parts of the country
reported crime doesn't get dealt with
i'm not saying it happens in devon but
let's hope it never does happen in devon
the other thing about janet was saying
about the report
well i just think that some of these
schemes that are
in here that the partnership are running
examples when i put case studies an
example of how
a process works would be helpful it
doesn't have to be pages of it
half a sheet of a4 should fill in
what the process is and i think probably
both
i can't speak for north devon but
possibly
it's the same for north devon council as
well as storage perhaps we ought to be
advertising on our web pages more
to the public how they if they've got
anti-social behavior problems
how they can report it and what the
process is when they do report it
we could put that on the front of our on
the front of our
web page and probably north devon could
do like i think janet did say that she
was going to put some case studies in
did i
hear that correct janet jan i i can i
can do that we do and we do have some
information on our web pages
um about um social behavior counselor
leather um
you know our website and sometimes it's
it's difficult to uh to find
and but certainly i can i can speak to
comms and just see if we can
reiterate that and bring that to the
fore in some way
that's no problem at all thank you um i
go now to mr topham our independent
non-elected member of external overview
and scrutiny for torridge mr topham
thank you chair um yeah i think this is
probably
for toby young but others may wish to
check in
county lines and cooking is a most
unpleasant activity
um whether it's dealing drugs or
anything else and i'm very pleased as
i'm sure everyone is that you're
you know you're getting on top of it in
this area but
gangs wouldn't be coming down here
trying to sell drugs if there weren't
people who wanted to buy them
um possibly in quite considerable
quantities
and i'm aware that there was a study in
london a couple of years ago which
suggested that a lot of cocaine was
bought by professional people
who were using it as a recreational drug
perhaps instead of or as well as a few
glasses of wine
possibly in ignorance of all the awful
things that happen further at the supply
chain
right back to the origins of growing
coker
and another little anecdote is
at the beginning of lockdown someone
said to me the roads are empty
apart from drug dealers delivering drugs
to people who
need something to get them through love
that possibly a frivolous comment but
uh i wondered therefore if
there had been any kind of mapping of
how
and who are using drugs in this area and
whether that might offer some guidance
because not everyone is an addict people
use drugs for all kinds of reasons
and certainly in the mental health
services you do have people who have
problems with a mental health
issue a mental health concern and a drug
dependency issue which makes it
particularly complicated
but there are a lot of people out there
for whom using drugs
is part of their life in some way and i
wonder if
perhaps we need to pay a bit more
attention to that
yeah we haven't got them here today
obviously but um
we have the drug uh services are
obviously a
an active member of the partnership and
sadly um there are hundreds of people
in in northern devon forage not unique
to to northern authorities it's a
national issue who are
who are addicted and often in some cases
a victim
to the circumstance that that led him
down that that particular road so
i think you may have heard me mention
earlier on that's why that trauma
informed that high intensity work if we
can get people off and we can help
all those other services partners we can
do everything we can to support those
people in a really bad place
we take away that you're absolutely
right take away the
uh the need for these uh i would say
drug franchises these networks to
uh uh target our areas so that that is
it will remain uh an area of focus and
honestly we haven't really got the high
end
i'm not saying we haven't got it we have
an issue like anywhere else but in terms
of the cocaine your professional circuit
that does tend to be
in honesty more uh located in your
cities city centers
we we work on we get masses across the
partnership and within the police
of intelligence coming through around
drug activity we will
we prioritize certainly around the
county line groups because they use
extreme violence sexual violence other
very unpleasant individuals that direct
it but
equally those that target our schools
our youngsters
uh equally they are another area that we
will put a huge amount
of energy into so rest assured
the partnership i know all the services
that are involved in this
uh this will remain undoubtedly one of
the areas that we'll be
focusing on continue to focus on through
throughout the next 12 months
may i just respond to that chair
i mean would it help to have someone
either
as an occasional visitor or maybe as a
permanent member
from the area of education and by
education i mean schools colleges and
universities
who might have a perspective
and offer maybe some connections because
as i say i think people use drugs for a
wide range of reasons
and with covid and possibly people
losing jobs or not even having the
prospect of jobs
for young people you might think that
there will be more people
in fact turning to whatever forms of
support legal or otherwise they can find
so yes i wonder if someone cannot just
respond to that i just
suggest talk to janet offline uh
i'm sure we'd welcome um some of those
connections uh
i do attend what is called the nordab
meeting
the north devon head teachers uh so we
do and we do have a structure
of we have partnership and officers who
are linked into schools
uh so we do and there's lots of programs
are doing some of that education within
the school as well so
but i think that that that's quite not a
really good offer and perhaps
you speak to janet explain that's what
you're thinking that we could um see if
we could get you invited along
or whoever you're considering or i might
know
someone i'll speak to janet thank you
toby
thank you chair thank you um then we go
to coaster hudson
uh torres district councillor not on
this committee that always contributes
coaster hudson please thank you very
much chair
um can i commend to you all the
bite-sized trainings
uh the last one i attended was for
cybercrime
the amount of information and links were
absolutely terrific and i would
recommend them wholeheartedly
i think there was a problem about the
access to the training because it was on
teams
and i know a lot of my fellow
councillors will not have teams
loaded on their ipads i was fortunate
that i do have it
in my position with torres district
council
so please don't give up do attend these
they're super
um the issues that i'd like to raise
are that haven't been sort of alluded to
apart from
an increase in hate crime i would like
to ask toby davis
exactly what the plans are um to
raise the profile of this and counter
this increase and i would also like to
ask about domestic violence
because there were great concern at the
beginning of lockdown
that domestic violence would go
unreported unrecorded because people
couldn't get out
of the situations they found themselves
in
and how this has actually impacted
on the levels of individuals
experiencing domestic violence
so um i'd welcome her some kind of
response
please toby over to you
yeah cool i'll start with the the d.a um
i can say that i know that da services
will say they've had a significant
increase in contacts over lockdowns um
people a lot more complex uh issues
and i they're talking about 50 to 60
percent up
um in honestly from the police
perspective in terms of our reports
we we've stayed pretty static in fact
we've seen a slight reduction
um uh so that doesn't mean it's not
happening it just
it just is we're not actually
necessarily getting the reported is
going through but
the i without going through some of the
stuff we talked about earlier there's a
huge amount of stuff
um around domestic abuse and the hidden
harm
uh and encouraging people to report uh
it through and
and there's a huge amount of
safeguarding activity as well so
i think we've talked about that in some
of the in some of the updates
you did i just think you did you asked
you asked a question about hate crimes
in the beginning
yes so just on the hate crime stuff
is that we are in a fortunate position
here that the numbers we're talking
about are enough to mean that we can
review every single hate crime
every single hate incident look at the
patterns and make
and we offer what we call a an enhanced
level of service
to those victims uh as well so whilst
there's an increase
actually sometimes it's important that
we're encouraging people to make those
reports because one of the biggest
issues is has been alluded to by the
councillor
is people don't make the reports in the
first place and we don't know what we
know
so we work with a load of um local
groups here locally i did you know the
sunrise
group and others we have a local
reference group
i'm not sure if you're part of that um
but we have a local reference group as
well
with members of community so we can make
uh we can talk about things we're doing
and you can equally people can raise
from some of our diverse communities
concerns they may have
there's a lot of work we do at the
moment about disproportionality
uh around our stop search lots of other
activity which
probably is another one i'd probably
update on in a separate meeting
because there's a huge amount of stuff i
could probably spend half an hour
uh talking through that so there's
there's a lot of stuff but be reassured
any hate crime reported we will go to
the nth degree
to ensure that we are doing everything
we can not just to find out who's done
it
but to put support uh and signpost that
support
in and around the victim or the
reporting person
um i don't know whether any of the
the rest of the team wanted to come in
come in on that one as well
then i think phil will go
thank but um but yeah okay
thank you very much you gave uh you know
me a lot of reassurance
you have a huge number of priorities
with some enormous challenges
and i do commend you all for the the
work you're doing and the
innovative approaches that you're
adopting to actually try and
resolve some of these issues so thank
you very much
much much appreciated thank you thank
you councillor hodgson
um i got two more hands um i think
galaxy noah are you responding in in
this situation to what toby has just
said
yes i certainly am um
yes no please if you can uh add to the
discussion here
just to add to the uh to what mr davis
superintendent davis raised uh and
uh the the councils are raised about
innovation
a very good innovation we have in devon
cornwall's operation encompass so
if there's any um domestic violence
inner premises uh and we become aware of
that
we provide a document
which is reviewed by our central
safeguarding team
and before nine o'clock the next morning
contact is made with the school
if there are children in the house of
the domestic
incident so we provide that wraparound
support we notify the school the school
are then
in a better position to provide that
support and safeguarding to a child who
may be traumatized
because of what they've seen and also
they may make all the reasonable
allowances
whilst that child's at school that's a
relatively new innovation probably no
more than two years old
but that's working really well i review
that from a community safety point of
view
and make any modifications if schools
aren't providing
a point of contact but it's a really
positive beneficial
uh investment from from both police and
education
where we're specifically talking about
domestic violence
check this out check one more thing very
quickly
yes i got one more question after this
one toby and then it'll be
probably the final question council is
coming in
but just domestically really quickly
then
uh just and this is for all elected
members because
um whatever your thoughts are on teresa
may she did bring in some legislation a
few years ago which is
is quite fantastic uh in terms of
domestic abuse cases where we we attend
we often can at times struggle to get
sufficient to get a charge
or to get because it tends to be one
person's world against another
there's no corroborating evidence and as
such
um we've in a different situation at
times we had to we've had to return
the perpetrator back to uh to a victim
the the new legislation means that
senior officer of my level
can review the case and not on the
the beyond reasonable doubt i can use
the bands of probabilities
to make a decision that i believe
something has happened and i can then
prevent that individual going back to
that home address
for two days it then goes to court and a
court can prevent that individual going
back to that
28 days so in terms of safeguarding
protecting victims
it's unbelievable and there are many
lots of people out there who probably
don't know this
and they don't report things and they
don't come through to us because they're
just concerned about what will happen so
as the elected members understanding
that those these powers and these things
that we can do
to support victims is really important
and is far more likely to encourage
people to come forward so
just just a just worth knowing thank you
um coaster hackett i think this will be
the last question unless anybody has a
burning question
after that councillor hackett please um
and you do a lot of work with
these organizations you thank you very
much chair i sit on the police and crime
panel uh which met last friday and also
i'm the
um i sit on the csp for northern devon
and i'm the lead member for health and
well-being for torridge
um i would like to reiterate the word
said particularly by the last speaker
claire
um the work done by our team is
absolutely phenomenal and
congratulations all around
but one of the issues that i keep
getting asked
by the public and by other members is
concerning pcsos
and we have had a reduction in biddeford
and
we do need a visible presence on this on
the street
it is a deterrent and the police and
crime panel
meeting on friday i talked about
robbing peter to pay paul in the
respective we're using torridge
uh officials who are csas trained
to enforce situations
that would normally be dealt with by
either warranted officers or pcsos
and that is a concern do we have any
figures
as to the amount of time spent on the
streets
with um pcsos or warranted officers
compared with over a a period of time
in recent years and be in comparison
with
other agencies such as street marshals
and csas trained officers that would be
my first question
phil i don't i don't i with this active
analysis is done in fact they've only
just done last week
some new activity analysis around um the
work of officers and
and pcsos that's happened whether
somebody has then tried to work out
how that translates against some of the
work of the street marshals
and you know which one street marshals
uh around covid but we've got street
masters there in the
that exist outside licensed premises on
evening nighttime economy times as well
um then i would probably uh rebut uh
feliz that
you say that um there are other areas of
the country and
in fact a lot of areas the local
authority have got
their the marshals as longer-term
sustained roles uh as well sometimes we
the the pcsos have stepped into the
space arguably
which isn't necessarily within their old
profile you are right about the numbers
going down
feel like you know i'm i've got my own
views you've got your views as well
i totally get um yeah and it's it's a
political
as a political st i'm not gonna get i
can't get involved with the political
statements
around it what i can say is we have got
less you know that
um what's important for me is from a
police perspective
i've got to create the time and space so
that they can just do their job
because they do get pulled and opposed
to do other things so if
my role is and the leadership that i
need to show my team
is to ensure that they can be protected
to be that visible resource that you can
see
out about and doing the stuff they
should be doing not pulled away
doing stuff where they're locked in a
room where you can't see them so
so that that's that's the commitment you
get from me and
i would be keen for the there to be a
discussion as you know for the
partnership
about sustaining uh some of the activity
and some of those powers that you've
talked about with with others as well
because um and we've got volunteers in
the mix as well now
so there's lots of opportunity as well
so perhaps a discussion
going on but i the bigger things around
the ptsos i leave with you in the
and the police crime panel which uh i'm
sure you were
you will air your views i i certainly i
certainly do
um one of the issues was partially
raised
by um phil topham and that's the
county lines we do know where these
drugs are coming from
we know that it's coming from two
particular conorations
away from our area and i'm just
wondering if we are using apnr
camera intelligence to stop and search
vehicles coming down the north devon
link road
do we have the facility to do that is
that taking place
yes it is uh and for obvious reasons
there are
over techniques and there are covert
techniques and some of which clearly i
can't we would never share
uh share here not publicly i do
understand that ampr is
is a we have an ampr um
uh recognition cameras they have
submitted
any vehicles that we believe the
connected intelligence those
registrations so we um
that's a core part of our day-to-day
business i can assure you
could we publicize it more which will
partially be a deterrent
from further ingress of these
terrible drugs that we're getting good
question
i need to think on that and i think we
need to think of that as a partnership
i can see the advantages um the
disadvantage would be that people
quickly coping on
that you could just uh avoid the roads
where the cameras are so
well we don't say it's a npr but we can
say it's intelligence-led
certainly that and we used some far more
sneaky techniques than that as well but
um in a positive way obviously but okay
perhaps a discussion outside of here
phil i i never thought of it
that way i appreciate it yeah okay and i
would like to congratulate you on the
work you've done
with what we'll call modified car
enthusiasts on biddeford key
and i witnessed a car that had obviously
been stopped
off the road going up to um asda
a few weeks before lockdown it's greatly
reduced
that anti-social behavior on the key and
i would like that to be kept a very firm
eye on because
i do get residents complaining to me
about that issue around biddeford so
that is something to very firmly keep on
the radar
thank you phil i'll feed that back to um
uh obviously i think janet and dean are
listening but equally to the central
perspective i know there'd be a lot of
work around that so
okay and and one last thing if i could
the effectiveness or non-effectiveness
of 101
has been highlighted repeatedly at the
police and crime panel
meetings and quite frankly
it is not fit for purpose in my personal
opinion
could we highlight that probably the
best way to contact our local police
is a simple text to our local
area or by email i think that needs to
be ratcheted up more because
waiting for 20 minutes plus on a 101
line
is not going to do your um
officers any justice in trying to
attempt to
keep crime at bay because people don't
report it
if they can make a simple text or email
they're far more likely to do it
especially with this day and age kids
just text something very very quickly
and it's probably more efficient for you
as well
yeah so there's i i would probably
moving out on the
the partnership elements the 101 but i i
am aware
of some of the the challenge um and i
know that's been picked up the first
level what i would say
is that you are absolutely right and
elected members all listening
is please promote the other techniques
for reporting to us other than the the
traditional
thinking of the phone so yeah via email
as uh alluded to um you will get the
response
um if not quicker and through using
those other techniques for the less
urgent matters but um yeah no thank you
okay thank you very much indeed chair
thank you thank you thank you ready for
all your
questions um there's no other blue hands
just a couple of comments from me and
just as a a follow-up
um obviously mental health has been
highlighted it's
hugely important just been aware a lot
of distressing things going on in one or
two families around
um and it's become evident i come from a
background i did serve
uh nationally uh when i worked with
samaritans
some years ago um to the rural community
and
um there has been a real i think i've
got
four different situations that people
have come to me
um in the last five weeks um
where it's been males in their 50s and
60s who have been really struggling with
businesses
going back to what council harding said
right at the beginning in his first
question from the target section
and secondly just um a group that i
really were in tim
i think mentioned this about the
adolescent safety framework
children in social care um i know the
children that were in
care always struggled because they got
put out on the street
so early on with very little protection
there was some protection
and i do worry when covered breakdowns
lower socioeconomic classes
groups are going to really struggle and
i just hope there will be some more
support
and we focus on these groups for our
youngsters for the future we are in a
low-wage area
um and a lot of youngsters are really
struggling um
and they're going to struggle when it
comes out of this so i hope that there
is that support for that particular age
group of work
other lessons go into adulthood um and i
hope you take that on board
having said all that i got no other blue
hands so i thank all
our contributors today um thank you all
very much for
excellent work you're doing i think we
have had a thoroughly interesting
meeting
um and keep up the good work we look
forward
to better times next year and i hope we
learn some good lessons from this year
as well
um and yes it is a safe area to live and
we thank you for all your work
collectively together in the different
organizations
i'm proposing that we split um cursor
tucker we thank you
chair tucker for the the meeting we've
had together tom can we have the torch
group on one side and the north devon
group on the other side is that possible
to finish off our meeting
uh no chair um i think if the north
devon councillors could
our councillor tucker could just sum up
and then
if north devon could leave we can
continue
mr tucker is that okay to you i go over
and remind our committee don't go yet i
know it's two hours in
um um but we need to just go back over
our agenda after
uh council tucker and thank you to north
devon for sharing
the meeting together with us today so
over to you counselor tucker
yeah thank you councillor pennington
it's been uh it's been very interesting
uh meeting thank you to tom vinson for
setting up uh the meeting and uh and all
northern district councillors for
attending and
it was good to talk in here torridge as
well so
thank everybody very very much uh and
uh we will leave you now in peace and
look forward to seeing you in person
well in 2021 thank you
goodbye all take care now thanks
everyone
yes thank you everyone we just take a
minute for it to settle down and get
ourselves sorted
phil do you i do you don't i take it you
don't need um
myself no i think that you guys have
done superbly i think the the present
moment uh we will uh
go into our we're just going through our
minutes now um i don't think there's
anything bernie you've got
all the records of the discussions to
the point as it came up and
you can bear those in mind for next year
and your excellent work has been
thoroughly appreciated by many members
of our committee so
you know you know where to find me if
you need anything else i take it that's
the same for dean
janet and noel as well so as i say for
the whole group of you i really
appreciate it
yeah thank you
thank you very much thank you jan thank
you chair thank
thank you tim thank you noah and thank
you you've told me so i think um i
included all of you there so
thank you for that
right let's look at the list that we've
got left online
oh you're still there guys that's good
yeah
okay yeah right we've got a full
torrance cohort here and now so uh
um we go back to our agenda
um just just to finish off from our
point of view
there is nothing on that agenda item
that you wanted to make as a firm
recommendation
just to send back to our to to the uh
north devon and target community safety
partnership i'm being brief here now
because i think
it's been very thoroughly covered by all
the questions from both members of the
council but if there was something
burning that somebody wanted to make a
point on i would take a blue hand now
and just have a
brief discussion that anybody wanted to
really make a recommendation
one recommendation from councillor
leather
leather yeah all right thanks chair it
might be more than one
but i'm looking at time now and we've
had a thoroughly thrashing of the
situation councilor leather
um so if you can come with a clear
proposition because we've got to go back
through the minutes and our forward plan
so uh just uh what is your proposition
for a recommendation
recommendation that enhanced promotion
of how
reporting asp is dealt with okay
um is that a proposition and yeah it's a
proposition because
[Music]
as i said when i spoke chair yeah um
i don't think we do enough to advertise
how this process
works so i'd like i'd like to see
enhanced promotion of that
okay is there a second or two that comes
with another proposition please
yeah i'll second it oh sorry sorry
coddle honking is that yeah i'd second
that we've got a lot
i think a lot of people in torrington
would be keen to
find out a bit more about that okay can
we put the
vote quickly please any other
propositions
or amendments to the the proposition
none
can we go through the vote quickly
please mary
yes church i could i just quickly ask of
the um head of legal and governance
councilor leather's not on the committee
can he make a proposal
i am on the commissioner he is on the
committee oh i'm sorry
i'm sorry you are yes he is let's see
him like
if it helps we'll put those comms out
anyway i think we agreed to do that and
that that's not an issue so i'm not sure
if you need to do as a formal proposal
we're always happy to
put those sort of communications out
with that satisfy you can do a formal
vote if you'd like
um but we're happy to ask
to do that okay i asked four
propositions because of the others put
it to the vote
you're gonna do it but let's go through
the vote quickly because it's been
proposed and seconded
proposed by council leather and second
by councillor carlo honkin
that we put some columns out okay cancel
kotlingen
council ford for councillor harding
or council hawkings oh
council langford oh kelsey leather
four council mackenzie
four councillor newton
or councillor pennington or
mr tobham chelsea's unanimous
thank you leather you said you had
another burning and i only want burning
oh no no chair chair don't don't don't
use the word burning i'm not talking
about anything burning
but i think in the in the report that we
have next year i'd like to see the
latest
asb police stats for northern devon
okay is there a second i'd like to see
this report far more information in it
so so your proposition is you'd like to
see far more information latest
latest latest ancestral anti-social
behavior
police statist statistics for northern
devon
in the report okay so there's your
proposition javier seconder
i don't see any blue hands going on my
screen
so the movie maybe janet will take it on
board and when i'm
compiling the report next year yes i
think it'll be sure if it helps i'm
happy to do that
that's no problem at all that helps
immensely janet thank you very much for
that so we move on
and we now conclude that agenda item
number eight so therefore we now go back
to
uh agenda item number two which was the
minutes of the meeting of the 14th of
october
2020 pages three to ten in your report
and first of all for accuracy
i wouldn't know to the bottom number
page is page
4 hand up from mr topham
mr topping your hands up yeah thank you
mine's for page two
on here as the agenda of the minutes
page two of the minutes
are you at the top of the page are you
yeah top of page two
no stop it i mean there's numbers at the
top of the page and there's numbers at
the bottom of the page i have on my uh
so so um it's then go to the top of the
page then we've got page one
page two which i think you got your hand
up for phil yeah that's right
uh well i'm showing this both having
agreed and be abstained
on that i apologize for that which did
you do philip i abstained
you abstained we take your cross out
there in that one there
thank you for that again for accuracy
page
three four
five six
and seven uh no han so
uh i'll approach the chair as a seconder
for the accuracy of the amendment
i'll second that chair who's that simon
thank you kaiser newton mary take the
vote please
ansel cottle hankin
or councillor ford or
councillor harting or councillor hawkins
for councillor langford
council or councilman kenzie
abstain
council newton council pennington
or mr topham oh
cheers 941 again one extension
okay any matters arising um there's not
dealt with the
wake up on the forward plan
okay just to report back to you that uh
we did a visit
um with ben nye this is on page two then
of the public participation um
council color honking myself and the
ward members
um um for biddeford north um
uh went to the palladium club and i
thought
mr and i was going to come to full
council but for some reason i don't know
why he did not
um and it was quite quite uh
surprising he did not attend or speak of
that full coaster but we did take action
on that
from that point of view um the rest i
think will come up as we come into
the uh um action list we go for from
there so see
there's no blue hands we then park the
matters arising
and we go on to agenda item number
four which is the action list
so you have the action most are
completed let's go down through the
pages
um we start then minute 25
um mr topham
are you happy with the completion of 25
uh yes thank you chair i'm happy i'm
happy with minute seven
minute seven councillor ford bottom of
page
that's bottom of the page 12 then
completed
yeah all right uh chair um
yeah basically um obviously i've had a
meeting
with them and it's being spoken uh about
friday afternoon at leadership which
i'll probably join in the zoom
um at least things are moving um whether
the outcome will be to my satisfaction
we don't know that yet but at least it's
moving
okay thank you right okay minutes eight
eight eight eight four there on page 13
i think you've been either closed or
completed anybody sure they want to
discuss it
no good and we go over the page we have
minute eight
play a space action close to be covered
meeting it and that's been dealt with
minute nine um completely completed
anybody want to discuss
those forward actions lists
none at all no hands good
so therefore the action list has now
been completed
so we then go forward to the i has
brought forward with permission of the
chair i have
sorry i had a blue hand then who was
that blue hand there's me chair
um basically on minute eight
about the uh play uh area and uh the
cycle track
i'm not i've not received anything for
it
okay uh that was coaster christie wasn't
it if i remember
the actionist again um can we just
uh mary get coaster christie to follow
up again and send us if we've been
remiss and not receiving them because i
know
i think i read something about it and
it's been lost in the midst of play
strategies and
um all the other things that have been
going on with the covet crisis
um so just revisit that again mary if we
may
get that sent out with councillor
christie from
one of you are you happy with that steve
yes thank you sir
good that's that one dealt with um
no i'm good item number seven urgent
matters brought forward with the push of
the chair
um i've been dying to see what the
fallout from richie sunax
outcome is because i think it will be um
dealt with when we come to our our
january meeting um be interested to see
where we get to with all this covered
situation
i give permission to anybody who's got
something urgent they feel is important
to the remit of this committee
and i see no blue hands here good that's
finished agenda item number seven we've
done
agenda item nine eight so we go to
forward to the forward plan
which i think we've got pretty well set
in stone
um at the present moment um
i had a uh even uh contact from
uh janet john williams john are you
still there
john i'm here
yeah yeah some um details from
i think it was sunriser from rightly
which was meant to mention this
afternoon can you put us
yeah we did we did mention in the
meeting about sunrise um in relation to
councillor hudson's question about hate
crimes so sunrise is one of the
um probably the main organization that
we work with in in northern devon
and for outreach and support of some of
our minority groups
and we have had an offer from sunrise
and from one of their executive officers
and we said that they'd be happy to come
and speak to the committee
let them know about the work that
they're doing um
it's it's an open offer so it's
something i can go back to
if there's that interest okay with the
committee's
permission i'd like to add it to um the
list of organizations
somewhere um on the back uh i'm not
quite sure which
box it would fit into health and
well-being i would imagine
and we add those to the list of
organizations that we put
to come and talk to us if it's needed in
the future
if you agree committee anybody disagree
but yeah ticks coming in there good
then we just list sunrise for the time
being as
going on to a list of organizations that
uh
could contribute to external overview
and scrutiny
mr topham your hands up uh are we we're
on the forward plan
yeah we are on the forward plan and we
have the meeting um
um not meeting until the 20th of january
when we're looking at a fairly wide
subject
yeah okay and we have westwood uh uh
housing and the agricultural bill on the
20
on the 10th of march may i may i make
some suggestions
certainly you can that's what the four
plans here for listening to you okay
on the 20th of january um we've got
mental health down
very important but i wondered whether we
could ask
a representative of devon partnership
with them being the nhs
body which oversees
your request um i i think the committee
since this committee has been in place
they wanted to keep the remits fairly
narrow
so we could be more in depth i just
wondered what other views were
to add the um uh
healthcare trust or the devon ccg
to to come along any blue hands
well i'm i'm not against inviting them
to join the meeting for a roundtable
discussion we have to sit down and scope
out this meeting fairly carefully
the january because it's a huge great
topic um
but if you're happy um i'm happy to
include them
um in that invitation okay
uh coastal langford um i'm just
wondering
i mean it'd probably be one body too
many to invite to that but
if we're talking about um health and
mental health
um would not is it sunrise that john
williams just mentioned
would not they not fit in there well
i i see no difficulty with sunrise
attending the meeting um and being part
of the meeting you know um
we've got to be careful of how wide it
becomes
um i think that that uh um you know
and any anybody can come and attend the
meeting yes not against that
i am just worried previous committee's
opinions are making it too wide
but i certainly am in favor of mr
topham's situation of
including the ccg and i think you said
phil
ccg and the north devon healthcare trust
and the two
i said devon partnership we used to have
a consultant who came
uh dr andrew i forget his second name
but
he was yes he was a long time back and i
don't think he's with us any longer
all right we can certainly inquire and
that goes back to meetings now we had
back in 2014 if i am
rightly it was a long time back
um but certainly we can ask for a
particular
emphasis from the mental health aspect
and the impact it's having
basically yeah so yes i'm
in favor of including that i've still
got my hand up if that's okay
yeah sorry yeah two other things yeah
and moving on to the 10th of march
we've got the agriculture bill which
probably will have passed through
parliament
but we will also have our relationship
with the european union
confirmed so
if we are going to have the mp it might
be best to
have a you know a general post-brexit
discussion there
whether he would whether he will be
interested in that i don't know
and what i propose is we further update
on the 20th of january
sorry somebody's in the background i'm
having double voices in the background
sometimes i hear voices they mightn't be
on the internet they might be in my
situation no okay um
i would just suggest we we finalize the
remit for the 10th of march
on our forward plan for the 20th of
january when we meet on the 20th of
january
okay and my third on the
28th of april and i i was
talking to the principal of petrov sean
mcnay
on another matter recently and you
remember he came to us about a year ago
and i asked if he would like an
invitation to come and talk to us again
yeah he said he thought that given that
he was only in post a few weeks when he
last came
it would be a good idea to come along
and update on things with petroc
so would that be a possibility for
for uh certainly could be a possibility
um does anybody
else have something burning for the uh
blank space we have
on the 28th of april
well i do have something else burning
for it which ties in with the petrol
proposal is that um
creating employment in north devon and
torridge
and educating upskilling people go
together
and so i don't know whether it's north
devon plus who are there key people
um or whether there's another group
which is promoting
employment and to have the two
together to have education and
employment on the same agenda might be
might be useful
who on our committee has got knowledge
of young
uh used to be peeps um wasn't it or
needs wasn't it not in employment
uh education and training they used to
be niche years ago
but i don't know what the the young
people's um and and
uh access to to training is at the
present moment is anybody on our
committee
expert in this area no we've got no
hands going up um
uh okay uh but there is quite a topic
there and charlemagne is
very fundamental to the area i see no
objection
um to penciling in that age group
if the committee are in agreement any
any any
uh any uh any thoughts
one hand from councillor leather yes
chair al sutton
phil topham's uh suggestion petroc and
youth
employment youth employment sure i'd
agree with that
very good uh simon newton is that simon
as well yeah
yes tim i would support that also i
think that's that's very good
that's exactly the level that we should
be looking at
yeah and the the impact of various other
national goings-on
we shouldn't be worrying ourselves
talking about the national goings-on
which are outside of our control
but we should be looking at the impact
on the ground here amongst our community
of what they actually mean uh there's
quite a there's quite a significant
difference between the two
um one one is what we're
we're employed or paid or volunteered to
do the other is
what some people are wanting to
interfere in doing um so
yeah i think um uh i think that's um
very right that we look at the youth
unemployment side that's
absolutely key especially coming post
the brexit decision
because i hope also that we we not only
on the unemployment but about the
training
and and the the pathways into work and
the whole lot's combined it it can only
be looked at as one
um the whole thing is is connected i
entirely agree okay mr topham i just
wanted to ask councillor newton
through the chair if he thought i was
going to be interfering in things
no no not a tortoise not at all no no no
no
okay that crap oh my gosh
i've been sitting too long medic medic
all right i'm all right
i need somebody to remember it's
dreadful
too long um okay um
okay so we've got a freight uh for 28th
of uh april
um um which is going to be then
youth uh training employment sean mcnee
from petroc
um so and we can think who else we want
to invite when we come and meet on the
20th of january
to keep that framework of that meeting
going from that place there
so is there anything else anybody wants
to add to the forward plan
no blue hands so i the wonderful time
of 1627 i want to thank uh all u.s
committee for all your questions today
you've done superbly i want to thank all
our officers today because they've done
a great job
uh particularly tom and mary um with the
doing
this uh zoom stuff because uh it's
worked
better than what i was fearing of
yesterday so i congratulate you
on your work as well um so thank you
everyone is there anybody else that i
need to thank because
you've done a good job today i think
it's been a very very interesting
meeting thank you
and at 16 28 i say the meeting is
closed goodbye everybody thank you thank
you chad bye